hey Hoss go embrace money spirit ha
welcome back to some more stray cat
crossing this game was so awesome I was
gonna wait until I played more but I'm
like I want to play now [ __ ] you you
can't control me
so here we go let's keep playing we are
stuck apparently he won't let you go
with you now and [ __ ] class alright
which button do I jump with there we go
yay oh it's a person I got a do it like
a like this BAM
oh god stop those [ __ ] things please
please uh oh great this is just what I
wanted let's go here the game hasn't
been that scary oh god [ __ ] me I take it
back what's with a [ __ ] baby crib the
game hasn't been that scary
oh do step I'll stop saying it if you
stop doing it the game hasn't been that
scary lately but I'll [ __ ] me what the
[ __ ] hey why did you leave us
no one ever gave us a chance why did you
leave us we never got a chance to live
why did you leave us why why why it's
your fault you know why did you leave us
how can you say why that fast oh I get
to save here Oh God that means we can
die here oh god alright alright let's
keep
okay don't leave ah ah ah [ __ ] yeah
hahaha let's try that again I press down
yes oh yeah you can sprint I forgot you
can sprint
sorry alright we can do this add sound
too much mascara bro oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yeah I don't like at all I can't stop
stop oh you gotta be really fast
oh god
this market heavy-metal music go gaga
yet oh wow
don't forget me even if you don't like
me anymore
please forget me oh it's you you have
some explaining to do cat
I just wanted my scalp did they didn't
make me any mouth
mommy was expecting them soon that
drinks so mami and Benny kind of name is
I didn't need me anymore
so I left that's why the twins are mad
you're twins
mommy and Benny they all died I killed
them
cat don't say that that's right
sorry okay I'm sorry let's be serious
this is serious oh boy cat I need to get
that scarf back why do we need to scarf
that badly if I was out after all that
[ __ ] I'd be like well you know and maybe
that burberry scarf wasn't that
necessary can't lose that scarf so we're
gonna go back in no way for us what do
you think all right then you said it
first we're going back in cats house
really thick ambiens isn't it hello ooh
it's you want to take a picture
I know I look good I know I look good no
doubt not twice oh she went this way
this time okay what do we got in this
room is a garden gorgeous music cat not
this again
all right mr. Zelda Zelda all hoot-hoot
who can tell me the time lunch time I
don't think I like the answer
Hojo Choate who will be my lunch - oh
God sorry about that pond or house
that's the pond now where's the house
then maybe that the time will change the
flow of the the ocean who touch who
dares telling now to sleep at night
thanks al
no that had no effect we could jump
maybe no we can't do let me try it at a
time him they would try them off that we
didn't try dinner oh lucky me I didn't
[ __ ]
Oh God never mind what they [ __ ] back
again Gary why had why do they keep
saying that we've been here excuse me
have a seat sweetie
now Pretender kettle you look like
something that crawled out of something
horrible sorry but who are you who am i
why am I
have you seen a little girl dressed in
green around oh you're my little cat no
I'm afraid I haven't seen her since the
accident what accident what accident
I'm so worried about my poor baby
you're oh god I don't want to see your
baby is it the RAM maybe despite oh god
it's oh the spider took your baby thank
God for that
it's taking my baby please bring my baby
back sweet attempts please don't call me
that
no kettle for me we need to bring back
the spider the time dinnertime was at
6:00 so we need three o'clock which
would be teatime it's a cool puzzle
really clever puzzles yeah but how do we
change the time oh my god I didn't see
this there's a bridge here come on oh
I'm so dumb how did I not see that [ __ ]
all right yes take yeah I don't need to
you saving right now sorry I got pissed
Oh Rama gonna earth I'm so angry
oh look it sticks up Takei I'm just
kidding well let's go this means we can
go to AA t10 yes genius paired strikes
again with the speed of räikkönen [ __ ]
yeah all right what no pictures for you
we're going to mmm
I'm cabbing oh god it's a spider web
okay hey you me yeah you ugly Thanks if
you need help
don't call me ugly come over here
you're calling me ugly look at your face
broski get me out of here uh you stupid
or something
hurry up before they come back what do
you mean by they Oh God
what the [ __ ] is that
Venice look who decided to join for
dinner you got a lot of nerve showing
your face around here
vanity I've been getting tired of reps
are you the spider a spider way ha ha ha
ha
I would Irene a spider she says a wolf's
genius
hey hungry gosh um do you mind if I take
this thing here thing a spring do we
mind if she takes that thing there I
don't know winter are there all the
seasons Oh a summer same question you
know freaking right we mind hey anyone
hungry you shut up autumn yeah can't you
see we're in the middle of some s22
deliberation here whatever the [ __ ] that
means
oh yeah well you're a farmer stop uh I
thought wolves weren't conjoined
together I thought so too you better
freaking believe it
it was that stupid Sphinx who's that I
told you all she was magic so hungry how
do they poop though if they they're
hungry they gotta poop we used to be
free wolves man that gosh darn liver
Idol yellow-bellied hag of a sling
stitched us together I told y'all she
was trouble that's it added awful with
y'all all you guys do is the yapper all
day all right well I'm just just gonna
just gonna go this has been great and
Hey ugly
yeah tell them you'll go ask for a
sphinx for a cure
uh-huh sure only it's our oh it's our
only chance
it's our only chance for it escape what
what you don't believe me fight it's not
like I want to be saved by someone ugly
like you it well thought do you
[ __ ]
I fine I'm sick of your words dragging
me down you want to talk cracker cracker
ass racist
I never liked any of y'all excuse me
girl you better have a real good reason
for interrupting
um I can ask the Sphinx for a cure
just a thought uh you'll you'll do that
you're crazy or something she'll eat
your line man I'm a woman but yeah
that's our job
ha ha ha but being free of these fools
would be nice fine go talk to the Sphinx
but you bet it can take or we'll eat
your head boy what about me
we'll be keeping this here till you come
back that makes more sense
not gonna lie you guys are cool I like
those guys are interesting characters in
this game to say that [ __ ] Lise
jesus-fuckin'-christ all right I should
be love this theme it's so pretty it's
like a picture oh sorry excuse me so
much there you go
alright so now it would have to be the
same time as before actually
yeah
because we need to go here first
genius p.m. strikes again and now it
would have to be bedtime is that the
Sphinx maybe well we haven't gone over
here so let's try here got a good
feeling but oh god it's so creepy
god damn it oh [ __ ] that sorry
okay what are we gonna get very
interesting music this must be way to
the swing slaves oh you must be the
Sphinx excuse me
ah see carotenes returns oh the girl
just now a member of my voices are you
the Sphinx Sam Kyle as this one Zach yes
haha but this one calls herself Z woman
the girl has come to ask if the woman
will separate Devils no she knew how did
you know the woman knows many things but
she cannot honor the girl's request I
like when she real like talk to her
seven third person
when our vile creatures will they must
pay for what they have done
why what did I do however it has been
too long since the woman has seen a head
Lama a what a head lava nothing will
make zero man happier if the girl brings
the woman a head lava then perhaps the
woman will separate Seawolves
okay why can I find the red Lara the
girl can find your head lava if she
enters the heads mass but we found the
girl may not come back out but are now
off she goes
good talk that's a vase with flowers but
also a vase without flowers okay yeah
well you said it the mace where's the
mace that must be where the angry angry
guy girl is this game is [ __ ] amazing
it's so well written and it has it just
reeks of wonderful atmosphere which is
why I love these games okay so now I was
bedtime we need there to still be
bedtime pretty much I almost [ __ ] up
again mind the flowers sweetie some of
them don't like being stepped on don't
get lost now it's not a tip that must be
a tip for the maze okay let's keep that
one in mind let's just save also pip it
picture
are you going to enter the maze
you shouldn't can't tell me what to do
you can't tell me Oh God oh my god this
is creepy don't step on the flowers well
I don't really have much of a choice do
I
okay
I'm trying not to step on the flowers
alright okay there's something here
you're not a red larva mind the flowers
or you will get lost
Oh God I'm trying to think oh god oh god
great what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we're back
here army oh that's weird
okay so I have to remember that where
I'm going so yeah what
oh god it's you
I'm looking for the red larva um hello
do you never can find the red larva
nobody is seeing in a real ever without
a password no you want the password I'll
give you a hint
everyone has one Oh God has one a dick
no not everyone has one a sign you said
I was sick you didn't mean it did you
you didn't mean it
hmm sphynx hello there girl um the swing
send mitt it what the swing sent you I
hate her get out well then thank you for
the talk
the password yes it's obvious once you
think about it girl
you're smarter than the Wolves Thanks
I'm out of here
okay whoa [ __ ] the mace oh god what is
this what is that another time is it a
moon
what are you strange thing oh there's
the red Lara she locked me here she did
please help me filled with just for no
less no more do these things always have
to rhyme yes sir with water I don't have
anything to fill with what about this
okay we got one small jar it's heavier
than it looks
we can't run with it but we can walk
with it we can gut absorb it got a jar
got a jar [ __ ] oh god there's snow yes
what am i holding then huh I wanted to
fill with what I got it's on my map to
heaven fill it
oh [ __ ] okay they've have different
sizes
last three okay so let's try this one
this one has two yards this is a math
puzzle fill it so one of them contains
five and the other one three so let's
fill one of them up and give it to this
one got it okay this is interesting
so let's empty that you're now put it
back and then we do the exact same thing
so that's once filled with two and then
we fill this we get four out of three
and there we go boom bada bing bada BAM
bada boom fun puzzle I liked it
fill it wait for nothing last nothing
more amazing I love this game thanks for
freeing me she locked me up because she
said I was stupid well I may be half as
bright but I've got twice the heart Hey
are we friends now I love you
haha yes sure what yay
I'll never leave you best friend oh
that's too bad a cassette oh no we're
gonna make the wolves eat him why why
are we doing this what's in the water is
that it looks like a dog on you know
what never mind let's get out of this
Mase that was not so amazing boo boo
take a picture you made it can it kick
in I take a picture [ __ ]
yes model Petipa wonderful so what time
is it now alright we needed to be yeah
that was it right she wanted the red
larva right Iran Iran Iraq boots
oh thanks game preciate it here you go
ah see girl late turns then she brings
in a lava yes I do
Oh give me side lava the light to the
level mention Jesus Christ English how
does it work
hello how do you do how do you know my
friend ah a fine color on this one
follows the woman please have you have
you met my new friend isn't he just the
grayness a la mer oh god what are you
gonna do to her don't touch hello don't
do that to my larva please oh [ __ ] you
you you just you just ate it doesn't
matter if you're sorry
the resolve of a woman must be strong
now the girl has done as she has asked
know
so the woman will honors a deal here is
the magic scroll will remove the kiss
all right we got a magic scroll let's
try it on the wolf's I'm pissed I'm so
pissed all right we're gonna I gotta
turn that episode there we talked to the
wolves in the next one this game is so
awesome
I'm touching boobs that are very far
apart all right so think about so much
for your support
leave a like and a comment if you want
more it really helps and thank you tell
your French tell your family I'll see
you in the next one
stay off